next time Kanye's going off on himself
I'm telling you just close your eyes
forget it's him and really listen to
what is coming out of this guy's mouth
he says [ __ ] like I'm a genius
I'm a God I'm Shakespeare
my biggest regret is I'll never get to
see myself perform live
that's a direct quote my biggest regret
is I'll never get to see myself before
in life dude you put that ego in a white
dude that is it benign and it's Thrice
and what's the blitz pink what's the
superior race
Vienna will return to Deutschland first
Kanye West appeared on Tucker Carlson's
show to defend wearing a white lives
matter shirt claiming he wore the shirt
because he was using a gut instinct but
what he's definitely not using are the
meds prescribed to him
he always AIDS
that's gay
here's a good rebuttal from Pete uh I'm
not gay I'm actually [ __ ] your
ex-wife
not that there's anything wrong with
that
[Music]
wouldn't that be weird though that's how
Kim found out
she was like you have AIDS he was like
oh yeah
and she's like and you're gay he's like
yeah this has been pretty terrible for
me I know
Kanye West anti-semitic tweets were
condemned by the black Jewish
entertainment a lot just say Lenny
Kravitz
Kanye West You gopher face Deutsche back
this week Kanye went on a media
Blitzkrieg he threw So Many Stones at
the Jews he's now an honorary General in
the West Bank which is soon to be the
only bank that will accept him yeah JP
Morgan actually canceled his account so
the only transaction Kanye is going to
have is when Caitlyn drops off the kids
so what exactly did yay say well hungry
hungry Hitler went on drink Champs with
the most bloated cheeks I've ever seen
on a human the guy looks like a ninja
turtle just had a root canal and
proceeded to spout off more hate than a
West Virginia water fountain he claimed
George Floyd was killed by fentanyl
wrong Kanye we have video evidence of a
throat getting crushed and don't worry
Kim's not in it he blamed the Jews for
trying to silence him yay the only Jew
that's ever kept your mouth shut was the
dentist that wired your jaw and of
course he defended his new shirt by
taking more shots at black lives matter
than Kyle Rittenhouse himself now I hear
some people saying Kanye did bring up
some very strong points yes these points
that's it Kanye isn't the free thinker
he claims to be he hasn't had a unique
idea his entire life he just
regurgitates the talking points to the
latest pseudo-intellectual leech around
him the only original thoughts Kanye's
ever had are Amber Kim and Julius so hmm
is Kanye insane I don't know I don't
think there's a mental illness that
makes you a Nazi outside of Mel Gibson's
ex-wife that being said selfishly I hope
he is I'd rather believe this is the
behavior of a guy battling bipolar
disorder then except I've been
supporting a Black Skinhead for decades
so my message to you chipmunk cheeks is
simple
get better better friends better
therapists better perspective on the
world and better meds and good luck
because you're gonna need it
[Music]
first of all you know Kanye yeah you
could tell that he was going to be a
star I didn't know until he did the show
and then my friend was telling me you
got to book this guy Kanye I said okay I
booked a guy and it was the day that
Jay-Z's Black Album came out
and it was me and and common and quality
and Kanye this guy that nobody knew
ain't no record stars and Jay-Z says on
one record Kanye stood up first time he
spoke all day he goes stop the record
and Rewind
who is this guy bro no one knows this
guy
I didn't know who he was everyone else
was like uh They're laughing like you
know they know I didn't know and then
afterwards we go to the edit and this is
when everyone knew came is going to be
start
and we were watching sketches we're like
yeah we could watch some sketches no
one's ever seen these before we show
them like the Rick James sketch and all
these great sketches and in the middle
of it Kanye's phone rings and he's like
hello
because no no I can't
uh no I I know because I met the edit
for the Dave Chappelle Show watching
sketches that no one's seen before and
then it goes like this
because my life is dope and I do dope
not because I don't like how much how it
looks
don't
you know
this is the real what we not gonna do is
you know you ain't gonna put me in no
Ford Focus that's not gonna happen
that's right
hey what about a Kanye West
yeah he's really lost his mind huh yeah
boy if that Kanye West and Pete Davidson
situation gets any more volatile Sean
Penn's going to show up huh I mean it's
getting ugly
holy hell
[Music]
hey guys have you ever gotten in trouble
with your girl over something Kanye West
said in a song once
has that ever happened to you well it
happened to me because I was with this
girl I was dating at the time in my
house on my sofa watching MTV okay Kanye
West comes on with his new music video
for his new song Bound 2 okay bound two
if you don't know the music video it's
the song the music video has Kim
Kardashian in it he's on she's on the
moon cycle right it's really tacky on
purpose because he's a genius all right
so watching this video Kanye West comes
on and one of the lyrics in his song
happens to be have you ever asked your
[ __ ] for other [ __ ] okay so he's
singing a song have you ever asked your
[ __ ] for other [ __ ] immediately the
Girl I'm dating just turns to me just
angry disgusted right oh my God can you
believe he said that
that's disgusting is that what you want
you want to ask your [ __ ] for the
[ __ ] is that what you want to do oh
time out how's this on me I didn't say
that I didn't even pick a channel you
pick the channel this video randomly
came on how is this on me and she won't
stop she keeps going right oh man that's
all men want men just want to ask the
[ __ ] but the [ __ ] men are disgusting
men are pigs men are pigs and she won't
stop I just [ __ ] screw it school you
wanna have this conversation let's have
this conversation okay because I went to
an elite law school I don't lose verbal
arguments okay
beat this until I win or one of us dies
all right you want to do this let's do
it let's break it down let's break down
what Kanye West is saying okay first of
all Kanye West is saying have you ever
asked your [ __ ] for other [ __ ] he's
not even asking his [ __ ] for other
[ __ ] he's asking the question have
you ever asked your [ __ ] for other
[ __ ] it's a hypothetical okay it even
happened what are you doing are you
punishing for his thoughts or your big
brother from 1984 okay second of all
let's put aside the fact that [ __ ] and
eubonics and Hip-Hop can also have
positive connotations in the right
context and let's take what he's saying
at the face value he's asking his [ __ ]
for other [ __ ] he's not just sleeping
with other [ __ ] he's asking his
[ __ ] you don't know what kind of
relationship they have maybe they have
an open relationship maybe like
threesomes you don't know you're just
applying your own moral values onto this
couple who's the [ __ ] now
[Applause]
and that my friends is how you win the
battle but lose the war
because I successfully argued my way out
that relationship
Hey listen you got something great
thanks for coming I'll see you later
[Applause]